Whenever you watch a Disney movie,
you can be sure there will be an
Easter egg or 10 hidden within it. It's
no surprise, then, that Raya and the Last
Dragon continues this proud tradition,
and we're here to help you spot them.
Although Pua the pig is a whole lot
cuter, as far as animal sidekicks go,
Heihei the rooster is the creature who accompanies
Moana on her adventure in her 2016 movie. Indeed,
the not-so-bright bird winds up traveling with her
across the sea after accidentally stowing away on
her boat. He might be dim-witted, but he still
manages to get into all sorts of shenanigans.
Alan Tudyk, the actor who provided Heihei's voice,
also voices Raya's pet and steed, Tuk Tuk.
Possibly as a nod to Tudyk's previous role,
Heihei shows up very briefly in
Talon's busy central marketplace.
Tuk Tuk is Raya's constant and adorable
companion and he's also her steed:
We most frequently see him rolling
underneath Raya like a living unicycle.
This isn't just a neat idea,
though — it's a cultural reference.
Tuk-tuks are a type of vehicle commonly
seen in many Southeast Asian countries,
also called an auto rickshaw. They
are open-air, have three wheels,
and get their name from the sound they make.
Tuk-tuks originated in Japan in the 1930s,
and went on to become popular throughout Southeast
Asia. Raya's Tuk Tuk might not be motorized,
but he does make a slightly automotive noise
as he rolls along the roads of Kumandra.
As Raya walks through Talon's busy streets, a
number of shots reveal a dog that looks somewhat
like a Xoloitzcuintli, also called Xolos, the
type of dog portrayed in Disney's Coco. In fact,
this pooch might just be a reference to Miguel's
beloved pet, Dante. Though the dog isn't exactly
a visual match, he could also be an Easter
egg in reference to Southeast Asian culture.
In keeping with the meticulous design of the
film, the Talon dog is most likely to be a
Southeast Asian village dog. Village dogs,
which are found throughout Asia, are not
quite domesticated, and they are not purebreds.
They are genetically diverse, and thought to
be descendants of the original domesticated
dogs of Central Asia from 15,000 years ago.
In an interview with The Hollywood Reporter, Lao
visual anthropologist Steve Arounsack discussed
several of Raya's cultural details, including
what inspired Sisu's design: the legendary Naga.
In Hinduism, Buddhism, and Jainism, Naga
are, according to Encyclopedia Britannica,
"[...]a member of a class of mythical
semidivine beings, half human and half cobra."
They have the ability to shapeshift and can be
good or bad, though they're usually good. They
also live near and in bodies of water. One big
difference between the Naga and Raya's dragons,
though, is that Naga have no legs.
Design-wise, this would've made it very
hard to depict Sisu holding the magical Dragon
Gem, so the design of the dragons was tweaked.
Depictions of Naga appear throughout the
lands of Kumandra. This reflects real life:
Naga have been carved into doors, adorned canopy
beds, and guarded gates in the form of enormous
statues. Basically, they're revered both in
the film and in actual Southeast Asian culture.
Raya's sword, which belonged to her father and
which she uses after he is turned to stone,
has a dragon and gem for a hilt. This repeated
motif is a depiction of Sisu, the one being who
binds the lands of Kumandra together, even as
they drift apart. Additionally, the dragons who
were turned to stone 500 years before the story
begins dot the landscape: When passing through
a valley full of the dormant creatures, Namaari
and her entourage make sure to show them respect.
But literal depictions of dragons aren't the only
way Sisu and her magical siblings are referenced
in Raya and the Last Dragon – water symbols
are everywhere in the film. One example is the
raindrop motif on Raya's cape. The dragons' powers
over water are a huge part of their magic — there
is no life without water, of course, and
rain is a big part of that relationship.
After the Dragon Gem is shattered, the
freshly-empowered Druun attack Kumandra
with terrifying strength. It takes Raya six
long and arduous years, armed with a potent
shard of the Dragon Gem, to search through all
of Kumandra's rivers and eventually find Sisu.
Raya grasps the exhaustive nature of her
search as well as the audience does: She
comments on how many tributaries the main river of
Kumandra has when looking at a map of her world.
Given that the main inspiration for that key
body of water is the real-world Mekong River,
it's no wonder it took her so much time:
The Mekong is about 2,700 miles long!
This mighty river flows through and between the
Southeast Asian countries of Laos, Thailand,
Myanmar, Cambodia, and Vietnam. The Mekong
is also associated with the legendary Naga,
particularly the mysterious phenomenon
known as the Naga fireballs. That makes
a Mekong-inspired river the perfect
setting for Raya's search for Sisu.
Much of the architecture of Kumandra resembles
Cambodia's iconic Angkor Wat temple complex,
especially in Fang. Inspiration taken
from the Indonesian rumah gadang style
of house is also evident. Though the
term "Southeast Asia'' encompasses
several countries, there are only five
in Kumandra, and so the filmmakers drew
inspiration from more than one when
developing each land's distinct look.
Consider the gorgeous, chaotic,
totally-filled-with-thieves floating market of
Talon. This unique environment draws inspiration
from two distinct Southeast Asian settings: The
Vietnamese water markets of the Mekong River, and
the luminous night markets of Thailand and Laos.
Such blended cultural details are also apparent
in the types of weapons each land prefers,
the type of clothing everyone wears, and
even people's jewelry. Raya, for example,
wears something very reminiscent of the
Filipino salakot. This combination of
various Southeast Asian cultures allows for
more of them to be showcased in the film,
while firmly establishing the
fictional style of each land.
Throughout most of Raya and the Last Dragon,
the audience sees Raya as the good princess
and Namaari as the bad one — though of course,
the film's climax reveals they have far more
in common than they think. One thing that is very
different, though, is their approach to fighting.
When we first meet Raya, she is trying to get into
the temple in Heart that houses the Dragon Gem.
In order to open a secret stone doorway, she
pulls out two bamboo sticks and puts them
in holes in the stone to turn and unlock
it. Those sticks are used in the Filipino
martial arts form Arnis, which is also known
as Kali and Eskrima. Arnis is mainly defensive
and involves fighting with sticks, swords,
and daggers. It is a combination of various
fighting forms developed over thousands
of years. Raya also uses Pencak silat,
which combines the art of movement, self-defense,
physicality, and spirituality. Furthermore,
Chief Benja's sword, which Raya wields after her
father is turned to stone, is an Indonesian kris,
which has a wavy blade and is considered to
be a spiritual object as well as a weapon.
In contrast, Namaari uses Muay Thai and Krabi
krabong. Muay Thai is somewhat similar to boxing,
while Krabi krabong uses weapons. Both
fighting styles originated in Thailand.
As Raya, Sisu, and their friends travel across
Kumandra, Sisu frequently suggests giving gifts
as a way of getting their merry band into the good
graces of the people they're visiting. The giving
of gifts is tradition in all of Asia, but there
are different customs in different countries.
Another important cultural norm is the
use of a hand gesture to greet others.
This is given a twist in Kumandra,
as the characters make a gem shape
with their hands when meeting each other. As
Steve Arounsack told The Hollywood Reporter,
"That's a creative take on the common
greetings you'll see in the entire
[Southeast Asian] region, where you have
clasped hands. It's called a nop in Lao
and a wai in Thai, but it's the same
theme of bringing your hands together."
In Kumandra, the height of the gesture
indicates the amount of respect given:
Sisu receives the highest greetings of all,
even from Noi and her mischievous pack of Ongis.
After Raya and Sisu meet 12-year-old Boun,
he winds up going with them on their quest
for the remaining pieces of the Dragon Gem. This
allows the party to travel aboard his boat — or
as he calls it, his "Shrimporium." Boun ferries
them from land to land along Kumandra's river,
but he doesn't do it for free — Raya has to offer
him some of her jade as payment. As they travel,
things become increasingly perilous for the gang.
Ferrymen frequently function as symbols
in literature and myth. Consider Charon,
a figure from Greek mythology who ferries
the dead across the River Styx to Hades — a
dangerous journey on a good day. The dead need
to give Charon one coin as fare for safe passage,
much like Raya has to bribe Boun with jade.
Likewise, at the climax of the film, all the
characters except Namaari wind up turned to stone,
a form of death that is undone once Namaari is
able to put the Dragon Gem back together and
defeat the Druun. The Gem is used as a form
of payment — albeit, one that brings the dead
back over the border to the land of the living.
Savvy Disney fans know that the studio loves
hiding Mickeys all over the place. There are,
in fact, multiple books and websites
dedicated to finding every "hidden Mickey"
possible. A hidden Mickey isn't an actual
drawing of Mickey Mouse placed somewhere,
as in a Where's Waldo? puzzle, however.
It's a simple representation of Mickey's
head — one larger circle with
two smaller circles on it.
In a recent interview with Malaysian website
Says, directors Don Hall and Carlos López
Estrada stated that there are hidden
Mickeys in the land of Talon, including
"tiny little" ones. If we're correct
about one of those "tiny little" ones,
then the three-dotted patterns on Talon
chief Dang Hu's hat certainly count.
Other possible hidden Mickeys can
be seen to the right of the kitchen
Raya and her father enter early in the film,
and on the larger of Raya's leather arm bands.
It's not a huge secret that Disney sometimes
recycles animation in its film. But sometimes,
a scene is less recycled than it is deliberately
echoing another Disney property. In this case,
the shipwreck scene in Raya and the
Last Dragon echoes the one in Frozen II.
In Frozen II, Anna and Elsa find a shipwreck
which turns out to be the ship on which their
parents perished. In what might be a wry
nod to that scene, when Raya and Tuk Tuk
come to the end of their search for Sisu,
they find a wrecked ship. Raya comments,
"Six years of searching and we end up at a
literal shipwreck." Is the film making fun
of Anna and Elsa's sad discovery? Probably
not. But pointing out such a similar scene,
even though it has a different outcome, is no
doubt a wink to the Easter egg-savvy Disney fan.
The Hollywood Reporter quoted director
Don Hall as saying that some of Raya's
"swagger" is pulled from Guardians
of the Galaxy's Star-Lord.
"Who?"
"Star-Lord. Legendary outlaw? C'mon."
That's definitely not the
only movie Raya references.
When Tong decides to throw in his
lot with Raya and Sisu, he says,
"I wish to join this fellowship of buttkickery."
We're counting this as a shout-out to
another fantasy epic, The Lord of the Rings:
The Fellowship of the Ring. Raya even wears
her childhood hair ring on a necklace,
after all, just like Frodo does with the One Ring!
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.